I want to conclude this course module with a
couple of pictures. One showing Xen and guests
supported on top of it. And this is
from the original paper which shows what are all
the resources available. And how they are virtualized
and how guest operating systems may sit on
top of it. With a similar picture for
VMware. As you know, Xen is a paravirtualized environment.
VMware is a fully virtualized environment.
And there's a picture showing how VMware
allows different guests to sit on top
of its virtualization layer. The main difference
of virtualization technology from extensible operating system
that we have seen in the earlier
course module is, in the case of
virtualization technology whether we are talking about
para virtualization a la Xen. A full virtualization a la VMware. The focus is
on protection and flexibility. Performance is important,
but we are focusing on protection and
flexibility and making sure that we are
sharing the resources not at the granularity
of individual applications that may run on
top of the hardware. But, at the granularity
of entire operating systems that is running on top of the virtualization layer.